so this is a highlight of my day even
though I ran with Olympic athlete this
morning Central Park I'm going to say
this counts is definitely the highlight
that they regard like you it is it is a
real pleasure to be here with Craig I I
was we were just talking backstage when
I was very very young and green 1989 I
was working for nature and I'd heard a
story that a guy at NIH had a gene
sequencer and this is the first gene
sequencer and I just had to see it I
actually didn't even know who the guy
was it was just there was I went there
to see the Machine and went to Rockville
and there was a kind of a converted
warehouse was it or something like that
and and and there I met I met Craig and
he hasn't changed a bit he was he was
visualizing at that moment pretty much
everything that came to be sequencing
supercomputers thinking of genetics in
in a new way and it great tell me that
you know that that was 23 years ago what
had you spotted then and what have you
learned since then that was wrong about
that initial concept that's actually
interesting looking back it's actually
kind of boring for me because I was
remarkably consistent that whole timing
yeah everything I predicted came true
and yeah yeah so it's a but I think the
surprise to me is how slow it's taken
the scientific community and the rest of
the world to catch on to some of these
same things and as a result now twelve
years after the human genome genomics is
just getting started you know it's in
the infancy in part because scientific
community in the same process with
understanding genetic disorders hasn't
changed you know it's the same look at
one disease look under the lamppost for
is using all this data that we have and
now it's cheap instead of a we lower the
price from three billion to a mere 100
million per genome hmm now stand around
four thousand dollars and so doing large
numbers we could do enough genomes for
the cost of the original project to
actually solve most genetic disorders
but that will never be undertaken again
because it all gets sliced back up into
these little tiny PI's that don't do
anything so it will tiny little tiny
pieces that you know where people look
just at their disease and the odd things
about genetics it's statistical
probability so not guess no answers so
it's a perfect feel for actuaries yeah
and that's what will be used by in the
future and so you have to understand the
statistical probabilities and you have
to have large numbers to get meaningful
data out of it then without the large
numbers and without all the digitized
phenotype we're going to keep crawling
forward and so leaping forward did you
know that vente the reason I ask is that
what you describe the notion of
probability the notion that DNA is not
destiny than you know it's a
non-deterministic nature of this when
you embarked on this 25 years ago you
get started I mean the notion of
discovering a gene you get a PhD thesis
for discovering a gene and you we're
just going to discover thousands of them
and you were going to run through sukham
supercomputers and you're going to treat
them like big data this was a radically
new concept at that moment did you
realize what Big Data was going to mean
to genetics this sort of statistical
rather than terminus ik yeah in fact one
of the reasons I left NIH is I tried to
get our bio informatics team promoted as
scientists at NIH and then IH
bureaucracy said no these are computer
people maybe over in the computer core
but they're not biologists and that's
not biology and so NIH has been dragging
behind because they still haven't truly
seen that notion that is large number
crunching it's a large amount of data so
we had to leave to be able to do the
at the right way and start building it
so all the breakthroughs that we had
while the technology looks cool it was
all mathematical algorithms and new
approaches
so without the computational part it
would have been an empty gesture
if advice to a teenager today
computational biology good good field to
go into so I get asked this how the fact
that there's no wrong field to go into
there's just wrong places to go to work
let's let's fast forward um so
everything you predicted came true today
they all the sequencing technology and
synthesis technology got faster cheaper
better now as you say four hundred four
thousand dollars per genome and
presumably will soon be four hundred and
then 40 you have two Institute's right
now that are doing just this what's next
where do you take this so I think that
the big advance you know it's more of a
conceptual advance anything else is what
we did with synthetic biology which when
we read genomes were digitizing biology
so we're going from what I call an
analogue code people argue with me
whether DNA is an analog or digital code
but I view it as an analogue molecule
and when we read that code we convert it
into the ones and zeroes of the computer
could you sit briefly say why you called
an analogue I guess just because it's
because it's a physical molecule that
you know is kind of clunky compared to
digital information and you know but
it's not really digital I mean I
consider digital the ones and zeroes but
people like to argue about that all
right and I figured you might want to
but but I hope not
so we've been cumulative those data as
ones and zeroes and so the assumption
that's gone with this is that DNA is the
genetic material and and people just
have accepted that even though it's
never been truly proven so we set out to
do the experiment of going the other way
starting with the ones and zeroes
recreating DNA rebooting it up to
recreate life and showing that every
a single atom in the cell was controlled
or derived from the DNA code that came
out of the computer so now the digital
and biological worlds have a complete
interface they're distinct and unique
and people as you know have been trying
for a long time to recapitulate the
biological code within the computer and
get it to simulate life and that's not
going to work although there's some nice
modelling work the study that came out
of the team at Stanford trying to model
our minimal cell have how you know large
numbers cellular processes where they
can track them in the computer but
biological life is truly distinct from
digital life because you can get genetic
changes in organisms either survive or
don't survive but the ones that survive
can go on and do something and with the
computer code it's very hard to get that
to happen if you get a change it kills
the program and then the computer dies
so but the interface allows us now to
switch rapidly between the digital world
and the biological world that you're
referring to the minimum genome project
also synthetic synthetic life when you
talk about now the synthetic biology is
just small small elements a little
little bits of gene function that's it
they do a particular thing you're
talking about an entire organism so
instead of genomics is a either a subset
of synthetic biology or synthetic
biology is a subset of that it's not
clear depending who you're talking to
but we're dealing with making the entire
genome out of starting with the digital
code in the computer in fact we just
finished designing three different
versions of a minimal genome that we're
about to do the transplants and find out
if they work it's the first time we've
designed an entire genome in the
computer but it's hard to do because
there's still a lot of biology that's
unknown so what you're talking about is
designing something computer I've been
synthesizing it in DNA then injecting
the DNA into a empty cell at risk well
it's actually not empty it's a recipient
cell what happens as soon as you put the
new DNA in the cell within seconds it
starts to get red you know
just how our protein robots work you
know they recognize the DNA they bind to
it they start copying it and the
proteins start getting made and some of
the early proteins that get made are the
restriction enzymes that my colleague
ham Smith discovered and got the Nobel
Prize for in 1978 so he's 81 and still
working at the bench every day it's fit
it's a great role model for young
scientists but anyway these restriction
enzymes recognize the chromosome in the
cell as foreign DNA and chew it up so we
start with the body of one species and
the genetic software of another and
within a very short period of time the
genetic software replaces everything in
the cell with proteins made from its
instructions in a short while we have a
new cell based on that new genetic
software and there's not a single
molecule left from the original species
so you completely convert one species
into another simply by replacing the
software you know Mac users wishes you
could do that just by replacing the
software and if you see indeed so then
when you say boot-up that's that's what
you mean yeah how close to that are we
well we can do it we did it with the
first synthetic chromosome that was
largely modeled off an existing
chromosome we made a number of changes
the team devised a whole new code so we
can write the entire English language
with numbers and punctuation we put in
some quotations and things like that so
to prove that it's synthetic we've made
these three chromosomes and so if it
works people will know about it soon
okay if it doesn't you won't hear
anything we'll just go back to the bench
and try another version well we'll have
another conversation on the need to
publish negative result that's right but
that's it but I bet I hear you oh you
just keep going to get positive one so
we we've been talking about advances in
gene synthesis and you know we started
with gene sequencing and now and that's
then 20 23 24 four years ago and now
we're gene synthesis is also on a
Moore's law like like approach when you
put the two together you start to
imagine a sort of mission
that can almost copy life I know you're
you're thinking about this now you start
to recommend it for us quickly kick in
but but tell me what you have in mind so
we've developed what we're calling the
digital biological converter or
biological teleporter and this is
important for example sample return from
Mars so we're building a sending unit
that we're testing out in the Mojave
Desert to robotically just take a soil
sample isolate the microbes isolate the
DNA sequence it and then send it up to
the cloud and then we just a little bit
there the Mojave Desert really the Mars
test site of the Mars test robot that's
just helped me visualizes a there's a
machine there take a look a Mars rover
like you know like with any of the
robots on Mars you just take a scoop of
soil and at Mars it's going to have to
be subsurface and so I think like
discovery will have to wait till we can
drill down below the surface a little
bit it's a question of how far you have
to go to get water but that's one of the
upcoming missions will be a drill I'm
with you on the drill okay and so we
have cell sorters simple robots that can
sort things down at the single cell
level and we can do a genome on a single
cell so a dirt or a soil sample comes
through and goes to a bunch of sifting
elements and we get little tiny
particles then you have another robot
that can figure out which one might be a
cell or it doesn't really matter because
you can just there will be DNA
life-forms there I think there will be
data life-forms you know when we do this
interview in 20 years you can say you
know once again the core addiction is
pretty fluorine now that's a and so
we'll just isolate the DNA in sequencing
on the spot and send that now digital
information when Earth and Mars at their
closest would take only four point three
minutes to get the the Martians back to
earth and a lot of people are concerned
with sample return and the Andromeda
Strain that eats the planet thing so now
we can rebuild the Martians in a p4
spacesuit lab instead of having them
just land in the ocean and a in a space
capsule and by rebuild the Martians you
mean synthesis
resynthesize the genome and booted up
and then have the cells here so so so we
have a sending unit and a receiving unit
right so so this is every step of this
this is not just sequencing on Mars and
synthesis on earth but also injecting
that see that sequence into a what kind
of cell I so we're trying to create a
universal recipient cell where we'll
read the genetic code any type that we
put in but we're also trying to get a
cell-free system hmm you know since the
60 so Marshall Nuremberg was one of the
first use to cell free ribosomes with
protein synthesis he was one of the
first he and Khurana were you first used
synthetic DNA and that's how the genetic
code was worked out they made poly a
poly and then read out the protein
sequence from what they got so it's it's
50 60 year old technology but all you
have to do is make the DNA you can drop
it in one of these little pots eating by
in a kit and make any protein DNA itself
is infectious if you're making the phage
like by X 174 and all you have to and
that's the first thing we made we just
made that genome you put it in any coli
he called I starts reading it makes the
viral proteins they self assemble form
the virus so once you can get to DNA all
life is is within the realm of
possibility so now we have a cell
producing proteins then what so you know
for the cell-free system the the goal
would be to get all the components there
enough lipid concentrations to form
micelles and also the phospholipid
pathways being produced from reading the
genome that we just Montaigne easily get
cell formation and good life it's it
will happen as question how fast it
happens maybe should bring up a slide
that shows us some of the machinery okay
on this I'll push a button and so what
part of it which part of the machinery
is this
so Roger Laskin at the veterans who
developed this process this is a cell
sorting device for sequencing single
seulji gnomes and this has been done for
we can sort out single bacterial cells
and actually do the genetic code on a
single cell what we're using it for with
human genomics is to get separating the
chromosomes from the parents and the way
we do this it is we can sequence single
sperm cells so everybody I assume knows
that sperm is just half the genome but
every sperm is different you know
parents are stunned their kids come out
different every single sperm is
different and every single egg is
different there's on average of one
crossover per chromosome per sperm cell
but all in different places so what I
say is we you know we have to sequence a
handful of sperm cells and by just doing
several genomes on single cells we can
get a complete separation of the heck
I'd genomes take that the full diploid
genome so and it's very important in the
future of genetics is to understand the
exact gene changes you inherited from
your mother versus your father and
there's a something that's largely been
ignored in genetics because they
couldn't do it and it's looking at
compound heterozygotes that's where you
get one set of gene changes from your
father and then the same gene a
different set of changes from your
mother and it creates variants that were
not part of the repertoire of most
geneticist even think about and it turns
out one of the advantages or
disadvantages of being first to have my
genome done and on the Internet as
people keep doing studies around the
world and publishing all the diseases
that I'm dying from you know I mean
really I you know the news is they
haven't realized I'm not going to die
from those childhood diseases but now
with the compound heterozygotes it's
narrowing it down where we can get a
hundred or so major gene variants that
could be of significance but there could
be is you know gets back to the
probability things of you know if you
have a greatly increased risk like I do
for Alzheimer's disease
what doesn't show up is why people with
the same changes don't get Alzheimer's
that's why you can't look at just one
gene and say you will get breast cancer
based on this information or you won't
get breast cancer
it's just probability statistics with
other genes and the rest of the genome
in your environment playing a role as
well so this is a very cool device that
separates cells and we can do this is
mostly based right now looking at stem
cells mm-hmm so we have a stem cell
genome project where we're looking at
the genetic changes in stem cells
because it doesn't matter whether the
embryonic stem cells or iPS stem cells
as soon as you take the cells out of the
human body the genetic code starts to
change first you lose methylation and
regulation and then you get these
changes so for stem cell therapy to be
effective we need to sequence the genome
and then go in and correct the defects
in the stem cells before you put them
back in and so I I've been studying this
more as a patient advocates because
there's labs in La Jolla looking at my
brain cells and tissue culture made from
skin IPS cells and I just got an email
yesterday we're making your liver but I
don't want these cells put back into my
brain they're you know because there's
so many oncogenes have been activated
just from this taking them out of the
human body so cell the cell contact is
important so it's an awesome machine
that Roger Laskin developed and back to
the teleporter metaphor this is the this
is the Mars side well this this would be
the the sorting side to get down to
single cells initially we don't have to
do that was the whole basis of how we
discovered the microbiome in the ocean
environment is we can just take all the
DNA sequence it and use the computer
deconvolute all the information so we
just need the sequence data there could
be 10,000 or Martian organisms in that
soil sample right we just get the data
back and we can reconstruct the
different species out of it okay so now
you send the data to Earth and let's do
the next slide and then so it goes into
digital data yes and then we convert
back yeah so we then will start with
four bottles of chemicals and this is
just a miniature miniature as a relative
term prism you know people just have a
small box linked to there
computer and you could download a new
vaccine from the internet insulin growth
hormone if you're an athlete it's only a
bike an Olympic athlete and so this
takes four bottles of chemicals and
rights to genetic code then we have
robots that assemble the DNA to make the
whole chromosome and then once you're at
that stage you can drop it in a pot to
make proteins you can boot up aphasia or
virus or we can make now simple
self-replicating bacterial cells so this
is a 3d printer for DNA yes or 3d
printer for life for life and let's
imagine that day where does become small
and cheap and and easy to use
and I have one on my desktop or everyone
does first of all why why would we want
one the most important thing is that not
really a good antiviral software because
maybe we should say real virus isn't so
you want to be able to screen out what
you're printing but with h1n1 it took
nine months to get the vaccine out mmm
two hundred and fifty thousand young
people died in the u.s. from h1n1 people
think there was really no pandemic but
because people under 30 had no prior
exposure to these antigens it affected
young people instead of people over 30
and we've been working with Barda in the
US government Novartis we now have a
version of the digital bioelectrical
converter Bardis sends us a test
pandemic flu sequence we have less than
24 hours to make the new vaccine and we
now have it down to under 12 hours it's
about 10 hours and so we're now building
one of these versions in North Carolina
the Novartis
vaccine plant so basically as soon as a
new pandemic strain is discovered we
make you know digitally design what
we're making it will go right there
the converter will convert it and they
can scale up making vaccine for the
world but we have this multi-billion
dollar plant just trying to make doses
for the US
and people might remember that you you
were either on the priority list or you
weren't for getting vaccine if you have
one of these devices on your computer
you're on the priority list in one
second we can send this information
around the world digitally and you'll
just download the vaccine and inject it
yourself and there'll be no more
pandemics so so this week I took my kids
to get their flu shot now this flu shot
is a guess at what's at what the you
know the D but the virus will be and
come flu season well it's more than a
guess but it is a bunch of old men
sitting around making a decision not
using a sequence information right and
and also before before that that
pandemic or before the viral flow
happens yeah but we will now change that
as well we my Institute is one of the
major centers for sequencing the virus
from around the world and we're
developing an algorithm to predicted
genetic changes hmm NIH is funded us to
make synthetic components of every virus
it's ever been sequenced so it's a
matter of a very short time of hours to
assemble any new vaccine as it appears
so we're designing it so we will have
vaccines built and tested before w-h-o
even sits down at the table to try and
make a decision
it could be tested and distributed and
if you have one of these conversion
boxes you won't even care what whu-oh
says in the future because you'll have
the latest digital information and
you'll just download it and have it so
the scenario is rather than at the
beginning of flu season we get one shot
what will happen is and you're in this
scenario when I have one of these we'll
get an encrypted email from the doctor
saying hey we got a we got a new a new
one out generated you get a little vial
of something out of this machine the
kids then sniff it at breakfast and
they're up-to-date maybe they do it
multiple times or Benzies no there there
is an inhaled version then there's an
injectable version though it's not clear
which depends on whose proprietary
information we can get use one company
has the inhaled vaccine that's met
immune so so I have to ask what could
possibly go wrong
well we we get a lot of spam email you
know people are making fake drugs and
selling them for profit I mean it's a
nasty world out there where people get
fooled all the time so you'd want some
kind of clear-cut validation that you
know the email came from a bonafide
source that you is reliable and that
that gets tougher and tougher I mean
people you know I get these emails they
look like they come from American
Express and that's some fraudulent
fronts someplace and it even gets
problem because you try and block that
email and then it blocks the real email
and you get behind in your bills and you
know so you know it's a problem with the
internet so how do you get reliable
information and when biologies just as
another form of digital information this
becomes critical hmm but the fact that
it's digital is critical when when h1n1
started breaking in Mexico City I get a
call from the mayor of Mexico City can
we you know could we work with them to
sequence it quickly and then
international politics intervene and
they were never able to send the actual
virus out of Mexico City
but if they just sequence it there on
the spot with one of these rote devices
it could have gone around the world
digitally and people could have started
studying it and making new vaccines for
it so it can change the practice of
medicine by having it be digital
information very quickly
this one says Synthetic Genomics Ron do
you intend to make and sell these yes we
be allowed to of course
it's a question wait you can download
didn't do with it right so you think
that you think that regulators won't
have a problem with gene factories or
little distributed life manufacturing on
our desktop is it's gonna be an
interesting form with all 3d printing
you know but all manufacturing is gonna
go to distributed manufacturing medicine
has to go that way
you know pharmacies will become a thing
of the past would be all just digital
information and you'll either have one
of these things that does chemistry or
makes DNA and and creates everything
from it and the only cost in the future
will be the cost of the 3d printer hmm
which are getting pretty cheap already
you said you have one in your desktop
yeah one of our board members has three
in his house I don't have one yet we're
making a biological and that's more fun
you know than making keychains or
something right now so dollhouse
furniture a lot of dog I agree that's a
little more impressive you know so
regulation is going to be an interesting
aspect of this and how do you get how do
you get accurate and certified
information versus bogus information we
have just a few more minutes before we
get to the questions but I want to move
to to energy and and your and your and
your work with with with algae and and
and biofuels you know one of the one of
the you know the big commercial aims of
your work has been to to find new
sources of energy and to modify algae to
be more productive it's a it's it's been
tough and maybe you could just briefly
bring us up to speed and talk about what
you think is going to be the the the
single thing you can do it'll make you
know biofuels viable and from a genetic
perspective
oh and Chris and I talked about this and
if I'm has nothing to do with biology it
has totally to do with government policy
hmm and without a price being on carbon
and having a carbon policy biofuels are
dead that there is no future in biofuels
whatsoever because if biofuels ever get
to be successful will cause oil prices
to drop and oil prices will fall and
kill
the biofuel industry once again stop
first explain why that is different so
one could say the same about solar or
wind or anything else Wyatt biofuels in
particular are they so born well I think
it's alternative energy in total you
know it seems to be a political debate
whether all this carbon we're
accumulating in the atmosphere has any
validity or not it's one of these you
know we're really playing Russian
roulette only there's only one empty
chamber instead of five empty chambers
right and for some reason we're a little
bit crazy with us you know the climate
is changing the environment is changing
and it's clearly due to taking carbon
out of the ground
burning it putting it in the atmosphere
you know it's not rocket science
not even genome science it's just simple
you know like President Clinton said
it's arithmetic and so we have to find a
way to change it until we put a real
price on carbon nobody's gonna make any
changes you know it's it's too tough for
people on an individual basis for some
reason to make the changes you know I'm
one of seven billion people on the
planet what I do doesn't really matter
but it does anything you multiply by
seven billion becomes a really big
number
you know you get seven billion of these
out there every day
that's a lot of plastic a lot of trash
so we're trying to use engineering to
use co2 as the raw material we're trying
to use sunlight as the energy source but
there's other you can get it directly
indirectly sugar is a sunlight driven
energy source and we're trying to
replace the plastic and bottles with
plastic made from either sunlight and
co2 or sugar and co2 but these are long
processes because we have to modify
something that hasn't really changed in
three and a half billion years and
that's photosynthesis I think ever slide
on it we've finally gotten a
breakthrough where we've modified
photosynthesis and improve the
efficiency for the first time and I
don't know how that well this shows up
both these are the same density of cells
the problem with what happens is cells
as light decreases they get bigger and
bigger
antennas they get darker colors and
shades everything below so you can only
get photosynthetic effects in this very
thin layer you see we have its surface
layer but you basically doesn't matter
how much water you have it matters how
much surface area you have and it's just
not enough surface area today in ready
and so depth is important yeah and so
we've made a we've altered the
photosynthetic process and so we have
the the lighter color on there right has
three times the photosynthetic
efficiency is the one on the left but
it's the opposite of what people thought
you know people that well you want more
photosynthesis you need bigger antennas
and more light gathering we've actually
decreased the antenna size and improve
the efficiency by a couple of other
changes so these cells obviously the
light can penetrate a whole lot further
and and we have about three times the
photosynthetic efficiency and this is
just one of the multiple baby steps
along the way to get there I think we
have another one that so that so just
just shows graphically what it would
mean as the light would penetrate
further and therefore you get a lot more
photosynthetic effect and more energy
captured from sunlight so people have
argued there's not enough photons
actually it's not a problem with the
number of photons it's the depth that
you can go and anything and you can
either go down a couple feet or you have
to cover more surface area and then the
surface area creates more evaporation
and just becomes unwieldy so this is a
baby step in the right direction and
where do you stand now competing with
with with fossil fuels I mean in terms
of you know dollars it's nowhere close
that were close you know it this is one
of those areas that needs another five
maybe even ten years of these kinds of
breakthroughs cumulatively adding up and
then you know if it gets to the levels
we're talking about it starts to change
the whole picture of agriculture not
just fuel production the corn you can
only get about 18 gallons of oil per
acre per year but the cells we already
have we're up around four thousand
gallons per acre per year our goal is to
get up around fifteen thousand gallons
per acre per year so oil palm is the
most productive plant and it's around
six or seven hundred gal
per acre per year so if we go up in the
thousands
this becomes the farming of the future
and we replace agriculture with things
that are 10 times or more productive
than anything we have right now so it'll
change food or will change fuel it will
change making plastic bottles but you
described you need to break through
senior political breakthroughs in
pricing carbon and then you need
scientific breakthroughs too you can
just listen one or two sort of things
that stand in your way scientifically
well I mean it's the hope you know we're
trying to overcome three-and-a-half
billion years of evolution where cells
evolved to survive in these environments
and in fact if cells did what we want
them to do the ocean would be full of
lipid yesterday instead of water so we
don't want these cells out on the
environment we want them in enclosed
facilities where they make a huge amount
of lipid instead of what they normally
do you know 40% of our oxygen comes from
these organisms so we don't want to mess
them up or we'll have to go to Mars
sooner we probably should take questions
from the audience now there's as you
know they will take them hands up in the
audience and there's a micro wait for
the microphone we're also going to be
getting questions from Twitter so I will
take one question from Twitter first
let's take a next question first could
you back up yeah so actually I don't
think I understand
Twitter problem 140 characters turns out
to be insufficient and scientific
questions
I'm a tweet a different one for you I I
think I think I mean it's just I one
question is about how the w-h-o and
other authorities feel about you're
relatively radical concept about
distributing vaccines well it's not
clear yet it's a pretty new idea and
it's not out there but I would think whh
should be excited about anything that
has a chance of eliminating pandemics to
really you know be excited so I opted
with my with my in my history with you I
realized that that your sense of what
large and sedation institutions should
do and what they do do are not always
the same
you have faced institutional opposition
your entire career is anything changing
right yes slowly but way too slowly you
know in the you know it's even looking
back at the history of science so I had
the the honour privilege of given the
Schrodinger lecture or 68 years after he
gave it initially on defining what is
life and looking back you know the big
experiment that proved DNA was the
genetic material have been two years
before I was born
and basically prejudice and bias and
science affects things just as much as
it does every other field you know
scientists are human too but there's no
reason we couldn't have known that DNA
was the genetic material in 1906 when
people were studying Drosophila
chromosomes right but the bias was DNA
was too simple of a molecule proteins
were more complex therefore protein had
to be genetic material that notion
delayed the discovery for 50 years so
bias and prejudice and narrow thinking
has been part of institutional science
forever and so it takes a while for new
ideas to get out there and change
people's thinking and change approaches
and that's been the history of discovery
from the beginning and it's you know
maybe it's good because only real things
get promoted to the next stage but it's
a frightening Lee slow process at this
new age of the digital world
let me take a question we have one in
the back and that will get one the front
so I'll take one from today yes sir John
Madison Kaiser Permanente question is in
large-scale software systems millions of
lines of code whenever we introduce a
new code release anywhere in that
ecosystem of code the chances are
there'll be some unintended consequences
somewhere else in testing and preventing
those unintended consequences is really
difficult so my question for you is what
can we learn from DNA about complex
system management that might apply to
software implement
what can we learn from our software
experience about manipulating DNA it's a
great question and we go back and forth
with the metaphors all the time the DNA
code has to be a lot more accurate when
we made the first synthetic cell
it was 1.1 million letters of genetic
code orders of magnitude bigger than
anybody ever made with DNA before and we
were so sure it was going to work we
booted it up and it didn't work and so
we have to do what software engineers do
we had we actually developed biological
debugging software to find out what was
wrong with our code we actually found
there was one base deletion in a central
gene so one letter being wrong in an
essential gene is the difference between
life and no life one letter being
different in the flu vaccine could be
the difference between having the right
antigen and the right protection versus
causing a new pandemic so accuracy is
really important to not have unintended
consequences and to have the
consequences that you want so the
accuracy of DNA sequencing even with all
the new instrumentation still not up to
diagnostic quality yet for human
sequencing so all this talk constantly
about we're going to recreate
Neanderthals like we don't have enough
and in other species from from the
genetic code is dis fallacy because it's
so inaccurate you know so we have to
have really pristine quality data and
you want to make sure at the other end
the receiving units can recapitulate
that in a good form so the challenges
are not trivial question here please
equipment becomes more widely available
what do you see as the potential for
the protections necessary for people's
privacy legal considerations as this
equipment and this information becomes
you know easily accessible from by
anybody yeah that's always been the
concern from the beginning of genetics
and genomics and and I sort of broke
that mold by putting my genome on the
internet and since then that sort of
became the trend and now everybody does
it then because what we talked about
earlier there's we're dealing with
statistical probabilities with your
genetic code not absolutes although
there are a few absolutes that do become
important with some diseases like I
don't think it's a real concern of
privacy with medical informations of
policy if it would be very easy to get
all your medical information in
anybody's medical information so it's a
relative privacy versus any absolute
privacy and if everybody's informations
out there it becomes part of the
collective that helps to understand it
that gives you more information about
your own genome and how to have a
preventive medicine paradigm so I'm
obviously not concerned about it the
biggest danger is if other people have
digital biological converters you know
my genomes been broadcast into outer
space now for 12 years people are
worried they might come back and lots of
Craig Venters come back and take over
the planet or something in some so you
may wish there was more privacy I mean I
want to make sure I understood when you
say that that that that people's health
information is easy to get do you mean
that their existing records are easy to
crack or that or that I you know can
simply you know shake her hand and and
get what I need from the sample well
I'll be above I mean just from the
coffee cup or the bottled water we could
decode your genome and so the notion you
know there was this really dumb argument
we had to fight early on we were doing
the genome is that you had to protect
the identity of the people whose genome
your sequence there's no more
identifying information about you than
your genome I mean it's the ultimate
identifier so you think by leaving off
digits of your name or social security
number somehow you're protected
you could decon dilute anybody's genome
just from a piece of paper from a copy
cup and so I think we need a different
type of dealing with the information
versus secrecy being the presumed
protection understood I'll take one more
question from Twitter and then we'll
take that question back there
um one of the questions was how do how
can other people how can the general
population participate do you do
crowdsourcing or or any kind of public
even gamification you know involvement
in your research well I mean on the
policy side it's really critical and we
constantly try to with discussions like
this for public dialogue and before we
made the first attempt even in the
synthetic virus you know we had a long
bio ethical review that was on the
University of Pennsylvania that was
published in science in 1999 the sloan
Foundation has been funding my Institute
along with MIT and on Washington think
tank to look at security issues and in
2010 when we announced the first
synthetic cell the Obama administration
asked the new bioethics Commission to
take this on as their number one issue
so I think the public dialogue about
this stuff is really critical to help
understand these issues about you know
where's privacy important because it's
not just your genome we didn't have time
to talk about the microbiome but you
know we have really fine beans so the
microbiome is we have 100 trillion human
cells but you have 200 trillion
microbes associate with your bodies it
doesn't matter how often you wash your
hands it's not going to solve that
problem
in fact it's essential for life and so
we have roughly 22,000 human genes we
have 10 million microbial genes in our
bodies and they determine whether you
get fat whether you get diabetes all
kinds of different diseases and so
understanding the microbiome and being
able to replace it after we wipe it out
by taking massive doses of antibiotics
it is going to be key for healthy life
and I presume that our microbiomes
differ even more than our genomes differ
yes and they they change in part based
on the environment so soldiers living in
the desert for a year
their whole mouth microbiome changes out
mmm
but it's been known for a very long time
h pylori is the bacteria that causes
ulcers and stomach cancer you can find
the relations between people by whether
they share the same strain of h pylori
more than they share anything else
so microbes tell us a lot about our
lives and where we're going so it's
going to be getting your gene I'm done
in getting your microbiome done or going
to be essential starting points in life
that we need to track throughout life
and understand how to change it
intelligently the question in the back
there could take the microphone to him
please thank you very much like I gotta
admit I'm scared of you okay sir mark
stand up so I can see I'll tell you why
I'm a toxicologist this one can you
please comment on the potential value to
clinical medicine of the metabolome the
proteome and the exhaled breath ohm in
comparison to the genome which I
associate the toolbox at the front end
and these other big data projects are
sort of a finished painting or the
current painting well this will be the
last one okay so even though it seems
like things are getting more and more
complex I mean they are but that's what
makes me optimistic that we can actually
get a reasonable answer so we know the
human genetic code now we can find out
individual variants in that we know
there is a thing called the microbiome
with 10 million or so additional genes
we know the impact that they have on
metabolism so right now instead of a few
chemicals going through your bloodstream
you have about 500 chemicals 50 of those
are made from bacteria and metabolites
of what you eat and in human chemicals
so we have all these variant components
that now measuring them for the first
time if we do large numbers and so the
value of the large numbers yet we need
at least 10,000 genomes tenth out
and complete phenotypes on those same
people just doing more genomes is
basically worthless if we don't have
complete digitized phenotypic
information all the microbiome data all
the chemical data all the clinical
history to go with it it doesn't mean
anything what if we put all that
together then we start to get
information that will change how we
practice health it becomes a preventive
medicine paradigm versus like we're
trying to do with the environment once
we wake up you know we can try and save
it but a lot of things by the time you
wake up you're close to dead so the
symplast is how people can participate
is you don't just need 10,000 sequences
you don't need 10,000 people's genes you
need them to reveal their entire that's
right the phenotype but basically
everything about about them their life
their history their family etcetera you
need 10,000 volunteers we'll pull it all
out there yep and there's more than
enough people that want to do that so
it's a matter of getting done doing the
genome is is very easy trying to work
out what a standardized human phenotype
is and how to digitize that in a
meaningful fashion is the probably the
biggest challenge for the medical
community all right well you have your
your opportunity here to be one of the
10,000 please join me in thanking craig
Venter